[Music]
did you guys know the definition of
emergency is a serious situation that
requires immediate action imagine your
loved ones under a rubble in earthquake
or bombs being dropped in Gaza or in
Yemen or in Afghanistan where there's an
earthquake bro sister we're working with
one um to get immediate relief to those
who are in need please go to the link
and donate whatever you can inallah and
let this be a that use for your use
there for your brothers and sisters when
they needed youal allum today we're
going to be responding to a video
between Tommy Robinson and Paul Golding
in which they're discussing that sneo is
actually funded and he's funded by the
Saudis so that he can spread Islam I
think that's all push though I think
that's all money I think that they're
being approached and given Financial
benefits like sneo I've watched as
Islam's become quite fashionable in the
recent years with lots of converts lots
of hot influential people do you see on
Tik Tok all the time you go on Tik Tok
every day you're scrolling you're
guaranteed to come across at least two
two white converts some some of them are
rapping some of them they're really
embracing it I think that's all push
though I think that's all money I think
that they're being approached and given
Financial benefits like sneo to P push
Islam and they get I think that I think
when you think about Muslim Islam and
Saudi Arabia Qatar all these countries
used to fund mosques and they'd fund Dow
stores to get out and promote and
convert people that shifted that's not
the way to convert people anymore this
is the way to convert people with
influencers so now they're funding the
influencers one of so this particular
accusation what do you think about this
one second one second are you trying to
tell me he's getting aab money I think
so or Iranian money sneo you been
exposed you're going to be you know
dealt with in a minute so you are
getting aab money how much do you get
how much are you sponsored if they want
to pay me I'll I'll take the money oh
okay so they're not paying you they're
not paying me end a video there's no no
Arab Money so there's then it's Iran
money first it was shy money shar's
spread Islam to the Western boys he said
that several months ago yeah the coad
yes the prostitute going coad right and
some people are saying like they want to
debate him they want to debate him like
if he wants to fight then we can fight
we at this point but he's very like I
met him he's like he comes to my HS yeah
that's why yeah is he yeah he's a [__]
someone ripped a flag from him and then
he just stood there like a muppet there
another time outside like a chicken shop
or something someone's walking so
someone's walking and then he falls over
I mean he's a coward so it's Absolut
coward not only that the funny thing is
though like the irony is you said a
accusation is a well from these people
from the Zionist every accusation is a
is a confession the funny thing is there
is not a single evidence that you are
getting funded by anybody but there is
ample of evidence Loki has spoken about
t Aviv Tomy being directly funded by
zionists like this is a known phenomena
that everybody knows let let exactly and
he's made this very clear that he would
even fight for them so he call himself a
patriot where he mocked the free deaths
of British Aid workers in Israel and he
said if you play stupid games you win
stupid prizes and you're supposed to be
a patriot you was going to start a a
Civil War in a riot that started in in
the UK you played a part in that this
could be even account to treaton so you
are here talking about patriotism and
you was having time having a t in Cyprus
while you sending a little foot soldier
crackheads drunk out of their heads so
if there's anyone that's being funded
it's actually you you're the one that's
been funded by Foreign government
causing corruption in your own land and
you know what's so interesting about
that it was the Muslims who were calling
for social cohesion alongside obviously
other people as well so the Muslims were
not saying let's go out and Riot and Rob
Gregs of all
it was the Muslims who were calling for
social and here you have a person who's
supposed to be a patriot a nationalist
and he's calling for social upheaval
he's calling for rioting he's calling
for Anarchy in a country and what does
that lead to one night of Anarchy in a
country is something that could lead to
mass killings Mass rapes Mass robberies
total Destruction look what happened
during the London riots it nearly
happened but the people of Britain who
are mostly peaceloving people they
realized this is just an agenda which we
don't to fall into and thank government
so they can take the agenda of what
they're doing in Palestine the
atrocities they com to Palestine they
wanted to change it and they use this
little intellectual flipping [__] to
do that and it didn't work and I believe
this scumbag his hatred for Islam is
greater than his love for his country
and those innocent free girls that were
used as a porn to start these riots
because the person that did was who Axel
yes this guy who was a church-going
individual yes but they don't talk about
that and then not only that in leester
square where we do da there was a a
little girl 11-year-old girl who was
being stabbed by a a Romanian Christian
country again yes and who who saved them
a Muslim security guard came to the
rescue which we interviewed a Pakistani
migrant who his families like Scholars
Etc so did he talk about that I want to
take you back to something sneo was
saying to us before which is Islam is
filling that void right and this is the
thing that I think you were saying
yesterday or today sneo about the fact
that for people Islam is an alternative
and which is why Tommy Robinson speaking
about the da he's speaking about sneo
being funded because they're realizing
there's a void and Muslims are filling
that void that they can't right cuz he's
trying to he wants to connect to the
Western Youth and he saw my video letter
from Mecca and he was he admitted in
that video that you're were talking
about like it was very good like he he
liked the editing he he probably it was
good D for him and so he put plug it
it's it's on Twitter I mean because I'm
banned on YouTube but um that video he
wants to have the same effect on the
western youth he wants to be able to
resonate with them that di was probably
so effective that even on the one of the
biggest haters of Islam he was like
starting to realize okay maybe there is
one God so he he to insist that I was
getting paid the the same way he's
getting paid I think since October 7th
are realizing that every accusation is a
confession the same thing they said
about the 40 beheaded babies and about
all the graping that was going on
they're doing it and it's not even a
conspiracy they're putting these people
on TV they said that Hamas was doing all
these evil things to taist they weren't
doing any of that there's no evidence of
that guys like Patrick B Davis says what
about the videos of Hamas graping there
are none it does not exist in fact the
IDF has soldiers that are being paraded
around on TV for successfully doing what
they accuse Hamas of so when you ever
since October 7th we realize that every
everything they try to blame us for
they're doing themselves they Tommy
Robinson uh Steven Yaki Lennon is the
real name is he's saying that Muslims
are causing riots and they're burning
and all this stuff that's what the far
right is doing everything that they
blame us for they're complicit of
remember there was a riot remember not
like there was a situation where people
were demanding that those people who
were forcibly raping those Palestinians
that that is a right just think about
that they're not writing saying this is
a false news it's for their right to for
their ability to do it more yeah it's
unbelievable man you know it's it's like
that you know when when someone is a
thief he thinks everyone's a thief like
him if you give him to your phone he
would never give you his phone to look
after because he'll think if I was to do
that i' would steal it so because this
telev Tommy Ked prostitute going scumbag
um he thinks because he gets funded
everyone's like him he cannot fathom the
fact that sneo has done his own research
and said this makes sense to me he
cannot fathom the fact like of course
Andrew Tate and many others they are
coming to Islam it doesn't register
they're thinking it's impossible there
has to be money involved they cannot
understand how how is it possible that
all of these people are coming to Islam
you know why cuz Islam is the truth and
this message of Islam the prophet peace
upon him said will enter every single
household and it's coming to a household
near you
inshah thank you me Allah bless you we
don't need to spread Islam by the sword
all I need is some good videos good da
Allah says in the Quran the scholars say
the greatest greater form of jihad and
you know what the scholars interpret
this say the Quran the Quran is the
greatest form of jihad if you just let
us you talk about freedom of speech let
us just do da W that's the only thing we
need we don't need Mass weapons of
Destruction let us preach the Quran W
I've noticed in the da tables that we do
yeah people are flocking to Islam bro we
cannot even keep up bro there's so many
we're thinking after you know after we
have for shahad yeah like you would know
for example praying and all this kind of
having connection you know all that
stuff it's getting difficult you know
why there's not enough resources so many
people come into Islam in and I hope and
I make Dua Tommy Robinson's children
come to Islam insh let me give you an
example off camera I was asking Ali dawa
for some of his prayer mats that he giv
some new reverts where it teaches you on
the prayer mat how to pray I was I
wanted to give out some more he's like
we don't have any more out we had 8,000
orders CU we give them for free we don't
charge them we give them out for free
for people to learn how to break we had
8,000 orders our admin team said can you
please take the website down we cannot
deal with it it's been nearly 1 and a
half month we've just sent about 4 and a
half thousand we've got another 3 and
half thousand before our new website
comes the point is what guys Salah
plus.com if you are a new Muslim or a
Muslim who doesn't know how to pay Salah
you can order it for absolutely free all
the Don that you give like I said before
I'm a trustee I don't get paid a single
penny it goes directly not like Tommy
Robinson donations coming in having
cocaine parties and going to prostitutes
yeah we don't do alhamdulillah every
single penny I got all the receipts let
me know what time is but that's the
difference because for them to spread
their ideology they do it for the sake
of money for cocaine we do it for the
sake of Allah ald you know what from now
your name is